ou ces innocents un mariage réjouissant
celui du secrétaire général de force
ouvrière marc blondel veuf et âgé de 58
ans qui a convolé cet après-midi en
justes noces avec sa secrétaire et
compagne depuis une vingtaine d'années
josianne legault baer surnommé
cacahuètes mariage aussi vite célébré
par le maire de saint géréon en loire
atlantique lui même ancien secrétaire
général de force ouvrière
commentaire du jeune marié il est plus
facile de signer le registre de mariage
qu'un accord avec le patronat
vous êtes de saint-herblain la
présentation c'était linda hardy michel
noir élu à saint géréon ou c'est juste à
côté dans ce n'est pas ton assez
longtemps pour vous mariez vous
comprendrez aisément que j'ai d'abord
été mariée une fois où j'ai eu deux
gardiens si votre compagne mêlée des
blacks ont aidé ben amor premier mariage
les proclame un temps non le besoin ne
s'en faisait pas sentir
nous nous étions en union libre comme
dans le temps avec des vacataires et non
non ça ne se faisait pas sentir ça s'est
fait sentir un moment où tous les deux
on discute on a jugé en ayant dans le
fond mais voilà c'est venu c'est venu au
moment où il le fallait